bonjour nouveau numéro de municipal 2014
des élections se déroulent en mars
prochain et nous recevons chaque mois
dans cette émission ce qui s'engage dans
cette campagne bonjour tout d'abord à
Aurore berger candidature MP aux
municipales sur Manille les hameaux et à
Bernard ensart bonjour à vous bonjour
candidat PSO municipale à plaisir à un
point commun entre vous en tout cas sur
vos deux communes un plaisir comme un
Mendy les hameau le maire élu en 2008 a
laissé sa place à un adjoint en cours de
mandat Joël réunion a laissé sa place à
Joséphine Coleman berger à Plaisir
Jacques lolliose à Bertrand Houillon
Amani Léo est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose dans votre façon de faire
campagne Aurore berger tout d'abord
honnêtement non c'est de la question du
Parti socialiste de savoir quel candidat
se présentera c'est pas mon sujet à mon
sujet c'est la constitution d'un projet
solide et d'une équipe de 29 personnes
c'est en cours justement de constitution
et de réflexion après c'est leur
problème c'est leur choix de candidat ce
qui me gêne toutefois c'est que ça
n'était pas annoncé puisque les
électeurs amanis ont voté en 2008 pour
une équipe RER et on change un peu les
du jeu en cours de mandat encore une
fois mais ça changera pas ma campagne
manières de faire campagne il faut juste
signaler que ça n'était pas annoncé ça
n'était pas prévu je trouve que c'est
pas forcément très correct vis-à-vis des
électeurs de changer en cours de mandat
pour plaisir là on est dans un autre cas
de figure puisque c'est la main en cours
de mandat exactement pour plaisir ça
changera pas les choses donc nous on
engagé notre campagne au même moment où
Monsieur Regnault a démissionné vous
l'avez annoncé le soir même je l'ai
annoncé le soir même pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'ambiguïté donc depuis je suis
devenu
officiellement investi par le Parti
socialiste voilà donc la seule chose
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on a d'une certaine
façon de deux mers en face de nous
puisque on a la candidate qui se
présente qui se représente en 2014 mais
on a toujours monsieur réunion en face
de nous donc voilà donc un moment donné
on nous dit la campagne n'est pas
vraiment engagée elle est vraiment
engagée nous officiellement et d'une
façon un peu plus souterraine du côté de
la majorité actuelle autre point commun
vous n'étiez pas tête de liste en 2008
déjà parce qu'on va verger vous n'étiez
pas à Magny-les-Hameaux on viendra sur
votre situation tout à l'heure Bernard
Ansar vous êtes rentré au conseil
municipal vous en 2009 vous étiez sur la
liste qui siège dans l'opposition mais
vous n'étiez pas rentrer au conseil
municipal c'est le décès de Patrick
Malivel ancien responsable dans le
département du Parti socialiste qui vous
a permis de rentrer dans ce conseil
municipal là c'est votre première
campagne sur votre nom en tant que tête
de liste vous l'imaginez comment cette
campagne le scrutin sera en mars on est
au mois de juin vous avez déjà une idée
de comment vous organiser les prochains
mois bah écoutez comme je t'ai dit tout
à l'heure on a déjà commencé cette
campagne là de activement depuis le
début de l'année on est dans une phase
d'écoute et de rencontres auprès des
habitants donc des plaisirsois on
profite de toutes les occasions de tous
les événements des réunions et des
rencontres individuelles on commence à
passer les grands messages de ce que
l'on veut porter devant les plaisirsois
c'est-à-dire une recherche de d'une
grande cohésion qui aujourd'hui fait
défaut dans un dans une ville qui est
très éclaté et où les gens se trouvent
très dispersés et pas forcément dans une
démarche de d'unité et donc voilà donc
nous on est parti de cette façon là et
le fait d'être de liste cette fois-ci ah
bah le fait d'être de liste moi je suis
très déterminé je suis comme je l'ai
déjà dit un ancien plaisir donc ça fait
40 ans que j'y habite c'était un peu la
différence par rapport à Patrick Malivet
qui était arrivé plus tardivement sur
notre ville j'ai une bonne vision de
cette ville mes enfants ont été élevés
éduqué etc et donc je pense pouvoir bien
comprendre quels sont aujourd'hui les
attentes après deux mandats d'une
majorité
UMP vous êtes arrivés à magny-les-maux
il y a deux trois ans
sur cette sur cette commune vous devez
donc vous montrer très présente très
agressif pour vous faire connaître
agressif tout de même parce que en tout
cas peut-être dans le bon sens du terme
on peut dire puisque vous avez fait
appel déjà à David Douillet à Chantal
Jouanno également pour venir
on est en campagne contre une équipe qui
est en place donc qui a des moyens de
faire campagne que nous n'avons pas des
moyens de visibilité que nous n'avons
pas donc l'idée c'était de nous faire
connaître d'aller à la rencontre des
manicois c'est ce qu'on fait puisque
chaque mois on organise des réunions
publiques sur un certain nombre de
sujets le 19 juin prochain c'est Pierre
fonds merle Sartrouville qui viendra
pour qu'on parle ensemble des questions
de sécurité qui est un vrai enjeu sur la
commune de Magny-les-Hameaux et qui est
malheureusement très occultée par la
majorité actuelle qui n'a pas envie de
voir que des difficultés en termes de
sécurité d'incivilité parce qu'il
faudrait les régler donc on est en train
vraiment de constituer le projet et puis
dans un souci de clarté c'était aussi de
dire qu'on était officiellement entrée
en campagne de toute faite à partir du
1er mars tout le monde est en campagne
sauf que ça n'est pas assumé du côté de
la majorité nous nous l'assumons nous le
revendiquons parce qu'il faut un moment
être clair vis-à-vis des habitants
responsable des Jeunes UMP à 19 ans
porte nationale ensuite des Jeunes
Populaires candidates aux élections
régionales aussi dans les Yvelines sur
la liste de Valérie Pécresse en 2010 pas
de campagne municipale en revanche si
j'avais été candidate à Versailles en
2008 et alors
qui a changé entre 2008 et cette fois-ci
mais déjà que pour la première je serai
tête de liste donc c'est un grand
changement parce que c'est une grande
responsabilité aussi c'est un grand
honneur quand parti politique me fasse
confiance pour conduire cette liste sur
Manille lamour qui est un enjeu
important pour nous dans ce département
et qui est surtout un enjeu pour les
manicois parce que je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses qui doivent être
changées aujourd'hui dans cette ville et
c'est la raison pour laquelle justement
on est en train de constituer ce projet
donc le premier changement c'est ça
c'est officiellement maintenant c'est
moi qui vais porter l'alternance sur une
commune c'est moi qui vais assumer ce
projet avec une équipe puisqu'on sera 29
évidemment sur cette liste les choses
sont un peu différentes à plaisir ce
sera pas tout à fait la même situation
parce que je vais tout de même préciser
que vous avez 26 ans que votre candidat
socialiste à lui 36 ans ce sera un duel
de jeunes on aura peut-être l'occasion
de l'évoquer au cours de cette campagne
ce sera donc pas la même chose
du côté de plaisir même si un point
commun entre vous deux vous n'êtes pas
rentré en politique au même âge mais
elle a même occasion c'est en 2002
c'était après le 21 avril c'est ce qui a
motivé votre rentrée en politique
pourquoi cet engagement en 2002 et
qu'est-ce qu'il a motivé peut-être aussi
tardivement puisque ce n'est pas tout
jeune que vous êtes rentré en politique
oui donc bon moi je suis resté très
longtemps comme on dit sympathisant de
gauche donc j'ai une carrière dans le
dans le privé et donc en 2002 j'étais
effondré quand j'ai vu les résultats de
l'élection s'afficher et je me suis dit
il faut que je m'engagement dans cette
dans ce combat pour que les choses
changent et que on ne revoit pas ce type
de résultat et donc de fait je me suis
effectivement
engagé au PS et donc dans la ferme
volonté de comment dirais d'essayer de
participer au changement au changement
des choses alors c'est vrai que je n'ai
pas la jeunesse d'Aurore Berger a
contrario
personnages me donne aussi une
expérience une expérience profil
différent dans la expérience dans le
privé et une expérience aussi en tant
que citoyen dans cette ville comme je
disais tout à l'heure une dernière
question juste avant de passer à la
seconde partie de cette émission
Catherine zulato va me rejoindre on va
aborder des questions d'actualité de
société une dernière question pourquoi
vous pourquoi vous seriez en mesure de
faire basculer vos communes respectives
à droite ou à gauche si on regarde juste
les résultats du précédent scrutin
municipales victoires au premier tour à
plaisir de la liste
ump5387% des suffrages et Victor au
premier tour à Manille de la liste
socialiste il n'y avait que de liste
63,74% très brièvement pourquoi vous
pourriez faire changer les choses
pourquoi d'abord la sociologie de la
ville de plaisir dans toutes les
élections intermédiaires se positionnent
clairement sur la gauche que ce soit des
législatives cantonales présidentielles
a changé entre la droite et la gauche
sur plaisir il y a une chose différente
c'est comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
Patrick Malivet était arrivé très
tardivement sur la ville et c'est
quelque chose qui a énormément choqué
les électeurs aujourd'hui moi je me
présente en tant que
ancien sur cette ville avec ses
connaissances je pense que ça peut jouer
énormément et le projet que je vais
porter sera un projet dans un large
rassemblement qui va de la gauche au
centre gauche
moi je me suis pas pas forcément aux
résultats précédents je sais pas ce qui
a une ville de gauche ou une ville de
droite je sais qu'on a envie de porter
un projet pour cette ville d'alternance
parce par rapport à la majorité actuelle
et clairement sur les questions
d'urbanisme sur les questions de
sécurité sur les questions de vie sur
cette commune sur des perspectives
d'avenir on porte un projet différent et
je pense qu'on a une énergie que eux non
plus parce qu'ils sont là depuis presque
20 ans aujourd'hui et que l'ombre du
patriarche Jacques lolliose plane encore
puisqu'il est systématiquement à côté de
Bertrand Huyon donc nombreuses années il
l'accompagne aussi celui qui lui a
succédé même cas de figure d'ailleurs
sur la ville de plaisir et ça
l'envergure sur plaisir toujours est-il
qu'à un moment nous on a une énergie que
de fait ils n'ont pas parce qu'ils n'ont
plus parce que ça fait 20 ans qu'ils
sont là et qu'au bout de 20 ans on met
plus d'énergie à durer que d'énergie à
élaborer de nouveaux projets et nous on
a l'énergie pour aborder de nouveaux
projets on va passer à la seconde partie
de cette émission juste le temps
d'écouter un autre candidat aux
municipal c'est François Siméoni du
Front national il est tête de liste du
rassemblement bleu marine à Versailles
nous sommes donc à Versailles devant
l'hôtel de ville bonjour François
Siméoni et vous serez le candidat du
Rassemblement bleu marine dans cette
commune dans la cité royale cet hôtel de
ville derrière vous vous le convoitez
vous imaginez bien pouvoir réaliser une
belle opération un bon score et pourquoi
pas si j'ai en tant pas forcément mère
mais déjà conseiller municipal pour vous
c'est possible et pourquoi c'est
possible bien évidemment j'envisage déjà
directement le poste de maire je pense
que le rassemblement bleu marine sous
l'impulsion de de marine c'est
particulièrement bien développé donc
j'envisage très sérieusement la mairie
de Versailles dans le but de de soutenir
les véritablement les versaillers comme
j'ai pu les soutenir lorsqu'on est
descendu dans la rue récemment pour
lutter contre cet abomination du mariage
homosexuel j'accompagnais donc les
Versaillais dans leur défense contre ce
mariage je vous affirme que le
rassemblement me marines parce qu'il
siègera à la mairie de Versailles le
mariera pas de couple homosexuel ni moi
en tant que mère ni aucun des de mes
adjoint voilà mais ceci dit ce sera une
obligation c'est ça sera pour une
obligation je lui explique pourquoi
Monsieur c'est très simple parce que si
je suis élumeur de Versailles Marine Le
Pen sera président de la République et
si elle est président de la République
c'est la seule qui a dit que la
brongerait la loi c'est la seule alors
avant de se projeter sur les
présidentielles on va parler des
municipales si vous le voulez bien
qu'est-ce qui a changé par rapport à
2008 au dernier scrutin ou dans le
département des Yvelines il n'y avait
pas de candidats du Front national ni du
rassemblement bleu marine qui n'existait
pas encore à l'époque c'était très
simple vous savez ce qui s'est passé en
2007 en 2016 Nicolas Sarkozy Sarkozy a
abusé les Français abusé la droite
française électorale droite en prenant
les nos propos et entre moi les Français
qui ont voté pour pour lui du coup vous
savez que comme les législatives
déterminent le financement des partis
politiques le Front national a été très
appauvri par cette opération-là et et on
n'a pas pu présenter le candidat et on
commence maintenant à revenir en
position de par les très bons résultats
ou aux présidentielles et surtout
législatives qui détermine le
financement du des partis politiques sur
cette commune de Versailles vous donc
peut-être de liste est-ce que cette
liste est complète aujourd'hui elle
n'est pas complète mais elle est en très
bonne voie en très bonne voie tu as
beaucoup de gens qui se sont
spontanément porter volontaires pour
être sur la liste ça va être une liste
rassemblement bleu marine il y a déjà
beaucoup d'adhérents du Front national
beaucoup d'adhérents du rassemblement et
des sympathisants qui se sont
spontanément présentés ce qu'on veut
faire nous au niveau du Front national
c'est protégé les Français protéger les
Français d'ailleurs quel que soit leur
origine quelque soit leur couleur de
peau quel que soit leur religion c'est
pas un problème protéger les Français
protéger les versaillers ça passe déjà
par les protéger d'une fiscalité locale
aberrante une fiscalité locale qui est
complètement délirante il y a aussi la
défense des biens et des personnes
défendre les Versailles vis-à-vis des
agressions qui subissent je pense
notamment aux jeunes gens qui se font
agressés dans la rue pour un oui pour un
an étant professeur au lycée je peux
particulièrement en parler des
cambriolages aussi qui sont une
reconnaissance importante dans
Versailles de ces de ces bricolage je
pense aussi au magasin qui ont du mal
dans surtout dans les quartiers comme
moserbes Bernard de Jussieu Richard Mick
qui a les commerçants ont du mal à
revendre leur commerce ou à obtenir des
prêts je pense à la notamment à la
boulangerie de la place d'Isigny à
Moselle donc des difficultés au niveau
commerce parce que il y a de
l'insécurité qui existe à Versailles
aussi et vous allez développer
l'ensemble de ce programme d'ici le mois
de mars Au mois de mars ce sera le
scrutin vous aurez l'occasion de venir
sur notre plateau des débats sont bien
sûr organisés merci François Simoni
candidat du Rassemblement bleu marine
sur Versailles